les munitions seront au cœur des
discussions lors des deux réunions
prévues aujourd'hui au quartier général
de l'OTAN ici à Bruxelles d'abord celle
du groupe de contacts dirigé par les
États-Unis qui outre les 30 membres de
l'Alliance atlantique comptent plus
d'une dizaine de pays extérieurs et puis
une deuxième réunion cette fois celle
des ministres de la Défense de l'OTAN
alors en effet le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN yens stolenberg a prévenu desire
que le rythme de production des alliés
ne suivaient pas les besoins
ukrainiens et ceux malgré des mesures
qui ont déjà été mises en place d'abord
à court terme en ouvrant par exemple les
usines le week-end et puis à moyen terme
en investissant dans les capacités de
production alors on sait que la
consommation
ukrainienne de munitions à
considérablement augmenter depuis la fin
de l'été dernier et la contre-offensive
et le pays va avoir besoin d'encore plus
de munitions pour contrer l'offensive
russe à l'approche du premier
anniversaire de cette offensive alors
ces munitions vous le savez le président
ukrainien veut le devenir Zelinski est
venu les demander en personne la semaine
dernière à Bruxelles en participant à un
sommet européen à cette occasion
d'ailleurs la première ministre
estonienne a suggéré la mise en place
d'un mécanisme d'achat commun de
munitions un peu à l'image de ce qui
s'était fait avec les vaccins lors de la
pandémie c'est sans doute une
proposition qui va être également
discutée aujourd'hui d'autant que l'OTAN
dispose également de son propre
mécanisme d'achat commun d'armes